this is one of the front lines in einel
hallway at the moment there is a lull in
the violence in lebanon's largest
Palestinian refugee camp behind this
barrier is a stronghold of jandashem and
armed group involved in the latest
factional fighting
this is usually a bustling market up to
60 000 Palestinians live in a 1.5 square
kilometer area people are scared to
venture outside
the situation is not stable we don't
know what to do many people are
displaced and living in mosques and
schools
stray bullets and Rockets are landing
not just inside the camp but in nearby
neighborhoods
several people have been killed and many
more injured
in some areas the destruction is
extensive
these are our homes our shops they have
been burned down everything has been
burned
the residents of einel Helwig are poor
Palestinian refugees have few rights and
are not allowed to hold jobs in many
professions in Lebanon
this was my father's shop he used to
sell coffee and cigarettes to be able to
buy food now we've lost our livelihoods
we are destroyed
the UN relief and works agency which is
a Lifeline for people here has suspended
services including Health Care since the
conflict began on Saturday efforts to
end the fighting have failed the
mainstream fatah movement is demanding
The Killers of one of its commanders be
brought to Justice
all those who are wanted by the state
who are entering the camp and using it
as a safe haven and they are armed every
now and then there is an assassination
and then the violence starts
thank you
this is what it's been it's been for
nearly a week
a week as rival factions struggle for
dominance in einel Helwig which is
outside the Lebanese government's
jurisdiction
[Music]
people here say they are tired and
scared they've watched shaky truce's
fail in recent days they say even a
permanent ceasefire won't be enough to
bring about a semblance of security and
safety here
the Camp's history is one of violence
and lawlessness for now at least there's
little to suggest that will change
Southern Lebanon
foreign